there's a real anal fixation
Freud would have a field day if he were
here this side of the room this section
here what would you like to hear a
freestyle
shouted cat before I'd even finish my
sentence
you're like I'm getting in there quite
literally
colonoscopy the first one you're quite
Young
so yeah you
absolutely not all right mate you know
just a bit homophobic to be that
the risk right people over here so so
far colonoscopy we've set the bar very
well you say Mushrooms Oh by mushrooms
do you mean delicious tasty the food
okay well food is Bam so the only way
you would have I'll let you go for a
second suggestion I don't want to feel
left over here mushrooms is a bit too
hit me again
flannel yeah so
oh okay
after colonoscopy the unimaginative
nature of this corner suggestions are
underwhelming come on here we go What's
it gonna be this section
Parton eating ass
for a real
fixation
Freud would have a field day if he were
here
colonoscopy and eating ass right
yeah yeah now we made that link
um
okay people in the middle of the room
what would you like a rap about
January
the [__] does that mean
you're just out here shouting months
are you born in January
okay yeah the story thickens ah
oh yeah no reason just just just just
yeah
January
what's your name
Rahul okay Rahul January would you like
that I did the little on the H is
because I don't know if you're Indian or
Spanish and it's hard to hard to tell
right
um January colonoscopy eating at this
corner of the room don't be as weird as
Rahul
what did you say
Pilates due to reformer or matt
both [__] Pro over there
and the only thing I know about Pilates
reformers is that almost every single
player in the NBA does reform and
polarities on specially made long
Pilates reformers but they refuse to let
people post pictures of it on social
media because
that man would say it is gay
that final section
being a mom you are a mom
right here I thought you're about to
gesture to your child I was like you're
a terrible mother what
how do we see that in so so The Who the
mom and how many children do you have
Mom
are you like her interpreter
she doesn't understand British people
it's a okay it's Mom's birthday so
you're going out and getting absolutely
[__] that's brilliant okay cool great
okay that mom who's got three kids
January you're [__] loving that
birthday [__] aren't you as well you're
like yeah make it about yourself Pilates
being eating us who would have predicted
that eating ass would be the high point
of these suggestions
okay well this is this is what we're
going to do we're gonna we're gonna do a
freestyle rap that's uh made up so Gina
do me a favor drop that beat let's have
some fun with this okay
this is for you mother not my mother
confusing for my mother the rhyme be so
funny got the mom over there in England
we say mummy easier to understand more
letters m-o-m upside down never forget
this that spells wow and I'm so proud of
you you're like one baby and then I'm
moving on to two never stop there I need
50 more add that to the two three ones
which do you adore most we've all got
the favorite unless the mum's drunk on
the wine she never says it maybe tonight
when you're celebrating your birthday
you're knocking back the Pinot Grigio
cause you're thirsty I need my mom juice
not mistake the job that it takes when
you knock back the grapes three little
kids proud of all three you may be less
from that time to time we see you on the
reformer or there on the map you're like
I've got to get my abs keep my stomach
so flat make sure I get everything tight
Pilates the only exercise that I like
I'm strapping feet my leg inelastic
moving there Joseph Pilates fantastic
the guy who invented it name after
itself kind of egotistical like you well
Rahul is saying Ever So Many Eyes On Me
born in January it's the worst of the
month when it comes to the seasons but
I'm saying it now for one reason I was
born there I'm basically the second
coming the price for a pool is my name
I'm the guy that you like with the nice
white jacket looking so fly careful you
got no stains inside it comes after
December that's all the gifts the
presents in your life now December [__]
January is the best wanna confront
February comes next but [__] that month
it's only got what 27 28 days January
coming through boo boo great incredible
got a lot to see on the camera on the
screen colonoscopy I insert this and you
know you're gonna get it put you to
sleep
aesthetic it happens to people when
they're in their middle age they reach
that stage they're like okay I'm tired I
need a little nap and so I mind the
colonoscopy inside the wrap they put the
fiber optic camera inside the do oh Dean
that's the big pool tube float out there
the large intestine doctor looking in he
asks you the question what you're
ingesting what you're digesting dude
well frequently my food is some lovely
mushrooms I put them inside done by the
fists I'm a fun guy you Mommy when I hit
it there upon the tongue I can see it
tastes like eating ass
[Music]
so it does it well got some tips for you
if you want to pay attention gotta relax
the anus less clenching otherwise the
tongue might get stuck they pinch in the
tiny little tip in that but there we go
that's the eating ass tips for you my
number one one if you're gonna do it
douche
oh